[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben da sind wir wieder mit
einer wirklich unglaublichen Geschichte
die uns nicht mehr loslässt heute Teil 2
ich bin Toni Heyer und zusammen mit
Mirko Kasimir erzähle ich euch jetzt wie
es mit der ICE Lady weiter ging hey Toni
das vollkommen recht das ist eine der
verrücktesten Geschichten die wir in
diesem Podcast bisher erzählt haben und
das will ich schon was heißen also
schnell wieder zurück in das Geschehen
am 7 juni 2011 lehrt in Wien eine
auffällig hübsche Frau namens
estebaliskaranza Ihr Konto und ein
Schließfach sie bittet ihre Putzfrau ihr
den Reisepass und ein Sparbuch zu einem
Treffpunkt zu bringen anderen Quellen
zufolge brachte nicht eine Putzfrau
sondern ein Freund die gewünschten Dinge
es überließ caranza bucht einen Flug von
Wien nach Paris und nimmt ein Taxi zum
Flughafen
sie ist an diesem Tag 32 Jahre und 9
Monate alt und wird bald den Rest ihres
Lebens hinter Gittern verbringen sie ist
auf der Flucht zur gleichen Zeit sucht
schon die Polizei nach ihr denn es die
ist am Tag zuvor aufgeflogen nach einem
Wasserrohrbruch waren im Keller ihres
Eissalons in der Wiener Oswaldgasse
zahlreiche Leichenteile gefunden worden
einige in Tiefkühltruhen die mit Beton
gefüllt worden waren
andere entwannen und Zubern außerdem lag
eine Pistole in dem Verschlag Nummer 6
es handelte sich dabei um die Leichen
der beiden Ex-Partner dieser Frau
ihren Ex-Mann Holger Holz hatte sie 2008
im Zorn erschossen zerstückelt und die
Leiche versteckt keine zwei Jahre später
begingen sie den nächsten Mord diesmal
aber eiskalt geplant sie erschoss ihren
Partner Manfred Hinterberger im Schlaf
zerstückelte auch dessen Leiche und
verfrachtete sie in den Keller unter dem
Eiscafé schleckeria
beide hatten sie ihre späteren Aussage
nach unterdrückt bedroht und finanziell
abhängig gemacht nach dem Leichen von
kreuzte die Polizei nicht sofort bei SD
auf denn der Keller war niemandem
zuzuordnen und so hatte sie erst am
nächsten Morgen erfahren dass da ein
Großeinsatz in der Oswaldgasse zugange
war
jetzt sitzt sie im Taxi Richtung Wiener
Flughafen um einen Flug nach Paris zu
nehmen Sie Bucht das Ticket aber sie
beschleicht ein ungutes Gefühl
schließlich besteigt sie wieder ein Taxi
verlässt das Flughafen Areal und lässt
sich nach Italien fahren
ganz ehrlich also wenn das ein Drehbuch
wäre oder ein Film den ich gerade gucke
würde ich ausmachen weil das einfach
völlig übergeilt und unrealistisch
klingt ja aber die ihre Realität ist
manchmal nicht so toppen denn
tatsächlich lag die Mörderin richtig
noch während sie wegfuhr warteten
Polizisten am Geld auf sie allerdings
vergebens
stattdessen checkt sie nach einer langen
teuren Taxifahrt in einer Pension im
italienischen Tolmezzo ein am nächsten
Morgen geht es gleich weiter es die
fährt mit der Bahn ins etwa eine Stunde
entfernte Udine und ich finde hier kommt
der nächste unwahrscheinliche move von
ihr es die trifft dort am Bahnhof von
Udine einen Straßenkünstler und labert
ihn an und dann bringt sie ihn dazu sie
bei ihm aufzunehmen ja sie muss eine
echt anziehende Ausstrahlung gehabt
haben aber und damit weiter im Protokoll
dieses Sommertages sie erzählt dem Mann
am späten Abend wird es Zeug über
Leichenteile in Wien und darüber dass
sie Selbstmordgedanken hat der
Straßenkünstler wird so misstrauisch
dass er heimlich die Polizei ruft und
jetzt endlich am 10 Juni 2011 wird es
die in Udine festgenommen Mirko was für
ein Ritter was finde Story ist er her
die Geschichte hat uns von Mexiko nach
Spanien geführt von Barcelona nach in
München von Berlin nach Wien ja und fast
wären wir noch in Paris gelandet aber
jetzt nach der Festnahme in Italien wird
diese hochgefährliche Frau an Österreich
ausgeliefert und ihr wird der Prozess
gemacht eins habt ihr hoffentlich seit
dem ersten Teil dieser Doppelfolge nicht
vergessen die Frau ist schwanger und
zwar von ihrem Freund Roland er den sie
erst kurz nach ihrem zweiten Mord
aufgetan hatte am 24 Juni 2011 wird erst
über liskaranza an die österreichische
Justiz ausgeliefert und kommt in
Untersuchungshaft
sie gesteht die Morde schon in den
ersten Vernehmungen kurz darauf
bestreitet ihr Anwalt dieses Geständnis
wieder und er fordert dass ein
psychiatrischer Gutachter hinzugezogen
wird der soll prüfen ob die Angeklagte
überhaupt schuldfähig ist jetzt beginnt
eine lange Phase in der immer wieder
Einzelheiten aus den Vernehmungen an die
Öffentlichkeit geraten bald schon macht
der Fall mit Begriffen wie ICE Lady oder
todeshexe Schlagzeilen außerdem kam der
Verdacht auf es die habe schon jeweils
vor den Schüssen versucht die Männer zu
vergiften das lässt sich aber nicht
erhärten und am 11 Januar 2012 bekommt
erst überliss im Wiener Kaiser Franz
Josef Spital ihr Kind damit beherrscht
das nächste Drama die Diskussion
die Kindsmutter und der Vater Roland R
heiraten im Gefängnis genauer gesagt in
der vernehmungszone der Justizanstalt
Wien Josefstadt aber das Sorgerecht
bekommen die Eltern nicht der Sohn
wächst bei den Großeltern in Spanien auf
jetzt haben wir schon juli 2012 und noch
immer hat kein Prozess begonnen immerhin
wird das psychiatrische Gutachten
vorgelegt
gerichtspsychiaterin Kastner hat sich 30
Stunden lang mit estiballys karanza
unterhalten der Befund ist 140 Seiten
dick sie Geld kurz gesagt als
schuldfähig sie solle im Falle eines
schuldspruches gut in eine Anstalt
weggesperrt werden wegen ihrer
besonderen Gefährlichkeit
weitere Monate vergehen am 19 November
2012 beginnt endlich der Prozess gegen
estebaliss wegen Doppelmordes die
Anklage wirft ihr eine einzigartige
Kaltblütigkeit und grubbellosigkeit vor
wenn man sich die Schlagzeilen der
österreichischen Adapter anguckt weil
lieber Scholli also das war ein
spektakulärer Prozess mal berichtet ein
Gerichtsmediziner das Zerteilen der
Leichen müsse eine große Sauerei
verursacht haben mal sagt ein Freund der
Angeklagten sie sei chaotisch gewesen
und gefallsüchtig aber natürlich sind
alle gespannt auf die Aussage der
Angeklagten den fraglichen Prozesstag
hat der Wiener Kurier packend
protokolliert
es die ballist erscheint in einem
grauenvollkleid das für den Geschmack
einiger Prozess Beobachter ein bisschen
zu sexy geschnitten ist um wie ein böser
gewandter hier zu kommen
sie sieht blass aus sie schildert wie es
zum Tod von ihrem Ex-Mann Holger Holz
kam und jetzt kommt die Opferrolle die
wir schon thematisiert haben und
vielleicht war da ja sogar was dran also
sie hat sich von Holger Holz getrennt
aber der will einfach nicht aus ihrem
Leben verschwinden und bleibt stumpf und
dickköpfig mit ihr in der Wohnung und
jetzt im Prozess sagt sie wortwörtlich
ich war absolut hilflos ich dachte ich
krieg mein Leben nie mehr zurück
dann nahm sie seine Pistole als er
gerade vor dem Computer saß und er
schoss ihn er hat es nicht bemerkt sie
sagt dann weiter sie habe nicht geglaubt
dass sie das wirklich tun könnte und
später mein Gott bitte nicht er liegt da
tot
sie sei wie ein gesteuerter Roboter
herumgelaufen den Körper habe sie nicht
anfassen können und deshalb ließ sie den
Toten tagelang im Sessel sitzen am 22
November 2012 endet der Prozess mit
einem Schuldspruch und einer
Verurteilung zu einer lebenslangen
Freiheitsstrafe wegen Doppelmordes und
mit der Einweisung in einer Anstalt für
geistig abnormale Rechtsbrecher ist die
ballistaranzas Anwälte liegen Berufung
ein aber das Urteil wird am 20 März 2013
vom Oberlandesgericht Wien bestätigt
wir brauchen von mir aus nicht zu
diskutieren ob das Urteil gerechtfertigt
ist aber mich macht dieses Kranke
Beziehungsleben von es die auch ein
bisschen nachdenklich ehrlich gesagt
weil wie vielleicht alle mal so eine
Ratlosigkeit spüren na ich glaube das
musste noch ein bisschen näher erklären
okay also nehmen wir uns noch mal das
Gutachten vor da steht sinngemäß sie hat
sich in Beziehungen stets den Partner
unterworfen seit dann aber dadurch
fällig unglücklich geworden und weil sie
zu unterwürfig war sich zu trennen hat
sie das dann durch die Morde gelöst also
ich persönlich höre da ganz viel
Unsicherheit und wenig Selbstwert raus
und ohne jetzt darüber urteilen zu
wollen auch keinen Mut also vor der
nächsten Beziehung musste sie die vorige
ganz radikal beenden ohne für sich
selbst einzustehen auf verbale Art und
Weise ja ich glaube ich verstehe auf die
hinaus willst die Sache ist wirklich
sehr sehr vertrackt ich sag mal so nur
weil sich ein Partner unterwürfig
verhält muss man ihn natürlich nicht wie
Dreck behandeln aber zu diesen Vorwürfen
die ästivalist gemacht hat können uns
die Opfer leider keine Fragen mehr
beantworten denn die wurden auf grausame
Art ermordet und das ist das was unter
dem Strich stehen bleibt und so müssen
wir unseren das halten was das Gericht
zusammenfasst sie hat nicht aus einer
Notsituation herausgehandelt sondern
vorsätzlich und geplant und das ist das
was einem dabei so ratlos zurücklässt
aber auch mit der Gewissheit dass sie
ihre Strafe verdient hat ja definitiv
ich finde nur ihre psychische Verfassung
und Rolle in der Beziehungen das ist
eine Erklärung für erhalten aber
definitiv keine Entschuldigung dafür ich
meine so die eigenen Baustellen bzw
Probleme oder Schwierigkeiten zu
identifizieren und reflektieren und
danach auch noch dran zu arbeiten das
ist eine Menge Arbeit aber so so wichtig
für jeden einzelnen Menschen und steile
These von mir mit einer Therapie hätten
die Morde vielleicht verhindert werden
können einfach aus dem Grund dass es die
sich vermutlich anders verhalten und
auch mehr Selbstsicherheit gehabt hätte
aber auf jeden Fall ist das ein
abschreckendes Beispiel für Beziehungen
die man besser lassen sollte ich glaube
zusammenfassend kann man sagen dass sie
sich hätte Hilfe holen müssen zumindest
in ihrem engsten Freundeskreis da hätte
sich sicherlich die Möglichkeit einer
räumlichen Trennung ergeben dass ihre
Probleme dann auf diese Art und Weise
gelöst hat ihre Partner einfach
kaltblütig umzubringen ja das zeigt für
mich dass sie ihre Strafe auf jeden Fall
verdient hat definitiv aber Mirko wir
sind ja noch nicht ganz fertig ne
ja da hast du recht fast jeder unsere
Fälle hat ja eine Art Nachspiel und es
die toppt auch da wieder fast alles
bekannte sie ist jetzt Ende 2012
verurteilte doppelmörderin verheiratet
Mutter eines kleinen Sohnes der bei
seinen Großeltern aufwächst und sie ist
Österreichs bekanntester Häftling tja
und was macht sie sie macht wirklich mit
der nächsten liebes-eskapade
Schlagzeilen denn auch die Ehe mit
Roland er steht bald vor dem Aus
stattdessen schafft es sie es selbst in
der geschlossenen Psychiatrie mit einem
Mithäftling eine Affäre einzugehen der
Mann heißt Martin l und wird nach
bekannt werden der Affäre in eine andere
Anstalt verlegt ist die Wallis bleibt
aber auch sonst in den Schlagzeilen denn
sie verarbeitet Ihre Erlebnisse in zwei
Bücher das erste schreibt sie mit Hilfe
der Journalistin Martina Pein es heißt
meine zwei leben die wahre Geschichte
der eislady darin schildert sie ihr
Leben
spannend mit ihrer Kindheit in Mexiko
bis zu ihrem Leben in Haft das verkauft
sich zwar gut aber ihr damaliger noch
Ehemann kritisiert das Buch und meint
man solle mit toten keine Geschäfte
machen das hat sie wohl kaum beeindruckt
zumal ich finde der Titel die wahre
Geschichte der Eis Lady zeigt ja schon
dass es ihr auch irgendwie ein bisschen
gefällt dieser ganze traurige Fame auf
jeden Fall ich glaube dass wir damit
ziemlich deutlich schon 2018 kam das
zweite Buch heraus diesmal geht es um
die Beziehung zum Mithäftling Martin l
und damit endet die Geschichte jetzt
langsam ja aber lassen wir zum Ende noch
mal es sie selbst zu Wort kommen da gibt
es nämlich eine Stelle im Geständnis die
ich sehr viel sagen finde es ging gerade
um Holger Holz und eine Geschworene sagt
zu ihr
ich habe nicht den Eindruck dass sie
etwas bereuen worauf es die erwidert ich
versuche mich zusammenzureißen wenn ich
die ganze Zeit Weine heißt es doch nur
schau was die für ein Theater spielt
später weint sie doch aber als es um die
Leiche im Sessel geht da sagt sie ganz
trocken der Sessel in dem der Tote
Holger saß sei aus Edelstahl gewesen der
sei ihr beim Segen in die Quere gekommen
das ist doch unglaublich oder ja sie
kommt da wirklich sehr kaltblütig rüber
sie trägt ihren Spitznamen ganz offenbar
zu Recht
wir danken euch fürs Zuhören den Fall
der Eis Lady haben wir euch erzählt mit
Auszügen aus Artikeln und Chroniken des
ORF des Kuriers von die Presse sowie mit
Zitaten aus meine zwei leben die wahre
Geschichte der eislady
Skript und Redaktion Stefan Netzeband
Schnitt Toni Heyer und weight watch
Studios München und damit tschüss und
bis zum nächsten mal eure Toni und